Imagine that you're looking for a stable
partner,
right,
so you might think,
well,
what do you want in a stable partner,
and at least in principle,
one of the things you don't want is too
much mismatch between you and that
person on the five fundamental dementia.
So for example,
if you're really extroverted and you
have a really introverted partner,
you're going to engage in continual
conflict about how much social activity
the two of you should what subject
yourself to.
And it's very,
very difficult for people who broadly
differ widely differ on those dimensions
to come to consensus because it's not
just a matter of opinion,
right?
It's really a matter of different.
If you're looking at extremes of really
different types of people,
and the thing about introverts is they
just don't enjoy large scale social
interaction.
That much one on one,
they're often fine,
but in a group they don't like that and
they.
It tires them out.
Whereas a real extrovert,
it's like you isolate them and they just
wither on the vine because a huge part
of what actually motivates them in a
positive way is tangled up with social
interaction.
And so if you're an agreeable person and
you have a particularly disagreeable
partner,
you're also going to run into problems
because the agreeable person will say
whatever you want,
whenever and the agreeable or
disagreeable person will say,
well,
I'd like to know what the hell you want
for a change and be much more harsh and
much more demanding in the situation and
the agreeable person is going to find
the disagreeable person harsh and
unpleasant,
and the disagreeable person who's going
to find the agreeable person wishy washy
and unable to stand up for themselves.
And again,
that's a,
that's actually one of the primary
sources of tension between men and women
because women tend to be higher in
agreeableness than men.
It's about half a standard deviation,
which is quite,
quite,
uh,
quite a,
quite a large difference by
psychological standards.
What that means fundamentally,
just so you have some sense of how large
a fact that is,
is that if you have a group of men and
women and you pick out random pairs,
the woman is going to be more agreeable
than the man 60 percent of the time.
So that's not an overwhelming
proportion,
but it's reliable and it's quite.
It's quite large by psychological
standards.
So there's the problem with
agreeableness with conscientiousness.
Well,
if you're conscientious,
you're industrious and orderly and
orderly.
People seem to be sensitive to
discussed,
which is something we'll talk about in
detail later.
We've had a hard time specifying exactly
what makes industrious people
industrious because it's hard to come up
with an animal model for that sort of
thing and there's no theoretical model,
but our latest idea is that it's not my
idea.
It's actually the idea of my graduate
student,
Christine Brophy,
is that industrious people find it
unpleasant and unsettling to to not be
doing something so it isn't so much that
industriousness makes them happy or
fills them with positive emotion.
That would be more extroversion because
extroversion is the positive emotion
dimension.
It's an industrious.
People can't stand sitting around doing
nothing.
And you know,
this is speculation,
but you know,
human beings are obviously always
engaged in the exchange of labor,
especially the reciprocal exchange of
labor.
And you can imagine that in a community
where everyone knows everyone,
the people who work hard are going to be
pretty irritated on a fairly chronic
basis with the people who are completely
unproductive.
And my suspicions are that plenty of
people who were completely unproductive
in the history of,
of our,
of the evolution of our species were
wiped out by people who were unhappy
with their lack of productivity.
And so I think generally speaking,
human beings have this sense of ethical
obligation with regards to one another
to share labor and people who are
conscientious really,
really feel that so they feel bad if
they're not busily working on something
that's productive all the time.
And so the advantage to being with
someone conscientious is,
well,
they're going to work like mad,
but the disadvantages there,
they're going to work like mad.
So you know,
if you're looking for a partner that you
want to relax with or have fun with or
who isn't uptight than a conscientious
person is probably not a very good
choice.
On the other hand,
if you're a conscientious person and
you're living with someone who's really
unconscientious,
that's good because they might be able
to help you relax,
but you're not going to be happy with it
because they don't work nearly as hard
as you do,
but even worse on the orderly dimension,
you know some of you have had roommates
and maybe you're more orderly than your
roommate.
What does it mean means you're annoyed
by mess before they are and you don't
have to be annoyed by mess much before
you're less orderly roommate for you to
be the one that's always running around
picking things up.
And so actually one of the things that's
emerged from the psychometric analysis
is that women are slightly more orderly
than men and I suspect that has
something to do with the UN.
What would you call it?
Inequitable distribution of housework.
Because even if you're imagine that your
proclivity is to be triggered by
disorder 25 seconds before your
partners.
Well,
you're going to end up.
It doesn't take much difference for you
to be the one that's always concerned
about the mess first.
So anyways,
and so if you're a really orderly person
and you live with a disorderly person,
well good luck getting along with them.
They're going to regard you as like
uptight and,
and,
uh,
over concerned with details and,
and,
uh,
and well,
and unwilling to relax,
that's for sure.
And there are going to regard you as
well.
Just a bloody mess and how can anyone
possibly live with someone like you.
And so,
so another reason why it's useful to
understand your personality is because I
think it gives you a better crack at
finding someone that you can actually
live with over the long run.
And we don't know what the optimal.
I don't think you want to live with
someone who is exactly like you because
then both of you have the same strengths
and weaknesses and there's a bit of a
problem there,
right?
Because maybe an agreeable person can
use a of a disagreeable person around
them to balance each other out and vice
versa.
Right?
So we don't understand the optimal
balance for,
for,
for longterm thriving in a relationship.
But I think we do understand the fact
that if you're too different in your
traits,
that those,
that where you're different is going to
constitute a chronic source of conflict.